Je vis avec l'idée de la mort parce que je suis
a grandi dans une région
J'ai rencontré des dizaines de personnes qui
puis ils ont été retirés mon premier
tué, comme ils l'écrivent dans le livre
Je l'ai vu quand j'avais douze ans
[Musique]
au cours des 30 dernières années, il y en a eu davantage
des décès dans le sud de l'Italie par exemple que moi
la bande de Gaza
[Musique]
nous parlons ici d'une économie qui
chiffre d'affaires 150 milliards d'euros par an
nous parlons d'organisations qui
ils en ont tué 10 en moins de 30 ans
mille personnes
[Musique]
J'avoue que je me réveille plusieurs matins
Je maudis ce que j'ai fait mais je
Je le referais cent fois parce que c'était
nécessaire de le faire
[Musique]
oui mais ces enfants regardent alors oui
ils inspirent mais quelle absurdité
Il y a un problème là-bas depuis vingt ans
la réponse et les écoles la réponse est le courage
[Musique]
mais dure depuis 26 ans dans ces
Je suis sous pression depuis des années
la pression du clan dei est énorme
Casalesi
la pression des narcos mexicains a plus
J'ai peur de vivre comme ça plutôt que de mourir comme ça
et donc tu crois qu'il peut avoir peur de
toi
bouffon